neil degrasse tyson here for star talk
coming up
brian green's latest book until the end
of time
well we don't know what that means but
we know what the subtitle means mind
matter
and our search for meaning in an
evolving universe
smackdown on star talk be there
[Music]
star talk cosmic queries edition
neil degrasse tyson here your personal
astrophysicist
and as is not always but most of the
time
chuck knight hey co-host uh good to be
here we just fist bumped in front of our
guests
yes we did bruce there we go now we'll
do a three-way fist bump
commutative property of fist bumps right
brian green is our guest
that's right we're doing cosmic queries
until the end of time
i didn't just pull that out of an
orifice it's going to say it is actually
the subtitle uh that's the title what's
the title that's the type
the subtitle what's the subtitle mind
matter
and our search for meaning in an
evolving universe
nice that kind of means everything right
that is
but doesn't the universe automatically
elicit
questions of what is my purpose my
meaning
why that's why we have them here to talk
about this for the show oh cool
i thought we were doing a cooking show
[Laughter]
so we solicited questions yes we did
about this book i don't know if people
read your book
already wow is that possible i am
looking at the questions i just know
he's got a fan base out there
and there is several of the questions of
people who have already
they say in your book okay so brian look
look at this one right here your book
until the end of time brings me to the
conclusion
wow look at that so there you go all
right so no
so this is the venn diagram that
overlaps his fan base
with our viewers there you go yeah
because we solicited it from our very
best so
there you go our people your people i
love that
all right so chuck you got the questions
uh just remind everybody how this works
it's cosmic queries
and these are solicited from our fan
base that's right i have never not seen
them certainly our guest hasn't that's
right chuck you might have seen them and
i haven't sorted them before
and brian green and i have ex very
strong
scientific overlap um but we're going to
get his view on this and i'll just sit
back and listen and if he's full of [ __ ]
i'll tell you no this guy will not sit
back and listen
i've never heard that before
what's funny but plus i should have said
it differently
no you won't brian knows almost all the
astrophysics i know
and i only know some of the physics he
knows so he can take my physics to new
places
that's very gracious i don't know if
it's true but it's very gracious thank
you
and and he's a he's a good mathematician
too all right yeah i mean i'm going to
say yes to that because he's
an astrophysicist and a physicist math
is a language
of the universe right yeah in which he
is fluent
very i'm delighted to have an all-time
friend and colleague
okay all right so let's do this let's do
this and as usual we always start with a
patreon
question a question from our patreon
patron oh wait wait wait
excuse me go ahead brian green is
professor of physics at columbia
university wow
and also joint appointed in the
department of mathematics wow
and he and his spouse co-founded
the world science festival here in new
york city
every year where science and art
and music come together to celebrate
science
wow that's right he does this that is
incredible it's not just some person
who's sitting between us right now
right this is brian he's still that he's
still
and i think this is his fourth book yes
right
okay and his first book that anyone
knows about was a
mega bestseller which was the lg
universe
the elegant universe and he's one of our
leading string theorists and this was
a way to share not only the frontier of
his research with all the rest of us
give us a sense of hope that maybe one
day we'll understand everything
cool or not or not so that was a mega
bestseller
and we shared publishers back then we
had the same publisher oh norton
with wwe north then he got so famous he
found another publisher
and then he published another book after
that and didn't do as well as the first
book
okay i just want to just just hang some
some publishers
you're just giving your publisher some
cred right now dirty laundry out here
there you go
okay brian green
alfred knuff publisher let's do this all
right here we go
uh as i said we always start with the
patreon patron because they give us
money
and uh this is michael tobias he says
hello neil
and brian i often wonder how far we will
journey through space
within our lifetime
will we be able to achieve interstellar
travel or will the human race go extinct
before we have the opportunity
and technology now he started off with
our lifetime but i think he means
the lifetime of the species of human
beings
because our lifetime the answer is no
and i am now
not not not an astrophysicist at all
okay well then we're done with that
next question no but within the lifetime
of the human species first of all what
is the lifetime of a human species what
would that be few million years
well that's a guess right well if you
look at this if you look at the
historical
the life expectancy of mammal species
yeah right
one in three million years somewhere
yeah but we're so much special right i
mean we have this thing on top of our
heads
to figure things out so so either that
is going to be our own destruction
because we can build things that can
kill ourselves or we'll be able to
figure out a way of living beyond the
traditional lifetime of many species
so unclear but um if you take let me add
to that question yeah
there's what's possible in the laws of
physics
and there's what's within reach with our
engineering absolutely so
give me your your read on that well the
laws of physics constrain
any speed of any spacecraft traveling
through space to be less than the speed
of light so if you're not going to play
games with imagining that we can
actually warp the fabric of space
and that's not playing games that's real
yeah well um you know it's unclear that
we'll be able to
unbe it's real in every movie i've ever
seen i agree
i agree but but taking the speed
of a craft to be less than the speed of
light then i mean achieving
uh great space travel is challenging
right now the weird thing is because
time slows down
when you have a spacecraft or a clock of
any sort that's in motion
you could have a spacecraft going out
near the speed of light
and we on earth would watch its clock
and its clock would be ticking off time
so slowly
that to the person on the ship they
would be able to go much further than we
would think they would be able to if we
didn't take that into account
right so so you know we could send you
know some intrepid voyager out into
space and they could go
and near the speed of light the speed of
light and they could go arbitrarily far
in their lifetime in their lifetime yes
so then they come back
home and everyone would have forgotten
about them because hundreds of thousands
of years would have passed
millions or billions of years absolutely
right right so that's not
that's not what people are imagining
when they're thinking of space travel no
i mean so but it really matters you know
if we were to take
you know a group of our species and send
them out into space it
really would be within their lifetime
that they'd be able to according to the
laws of physics go arbitrarily far
right right and it's kind of now you're
right the people back on earth they
perhaps would be long extinct you know
wow
imagine you come back and your species
isn't even around right yeah
and the roaches took over and the rats
right
and they say wait a minute you come back
and there's a museum that the rats have
and they're the skeletons of humans
there
right that long ago it's terrorized me
or they could even have you know an
homage an exhibit to the spacecraft that
left you know a hundred thousand or a
million years ago and you can sort of
see
the uh the origin of your own trip man
that's kind of cool though i mean you
could actually so okay so you can
but no one else can really participate
in that unless they're part of the
literal part of the little version
right right good good so now what about
this in terms
of when you say
you put these people on a ship all right
so you take a colony of people you put
them on a ship
and now you're they they go
and they're looking for some place to
live and now you're just seeding the
universe
you know uh or at least a cert another
part of our galaxy because you can't
really say the universe
you know milky way the milky way you
know because we're not gonna
how long would it take us to get out of
the milky way well millions of years to
the nearest galaxy
there you go right so but with that
sorry sorry
well it's hundreds of thousands yeah
right let's get this just get the
numbers right
so our galaxy is about a hundred
thousand light years across
so if we watch you travel at the speed
of light
we it'll take us a hundred thousand
years to observe that but you could
live an arbitrarily short amount of time
depending how fast
so that being said you in principle
could go to the andromeda galaxy two
million light years away
right we are long gone here maybe
and unless we're smart as brian wants to
believe we are
um and so yeah so you could go another
year
but in practice you want to you want to
pass my stars not
the void of empty intergalactic space
exactly right right yeah you want to go
someplace where there's
where there is something but brian's
point that i'm take to heart
is when i think of these ships i think
that they're generational ships
and they have to be really fertile
people make babies babies grow up
but i what what's odd is you will be
giving birth
to children who will never have known
earth
and that's that's kind of diabolical to
me because they would not have had free
choice
to have taken that trip do you have any
moral sense well you know i don't think
any of us have free choice or free will
so if you want to get into
hey let's just pull out two of those
worms from that can
yeah holy moly all right we'll get back
to that
i can't i can't yeah that's a big one
right there i don't have a certain
bandwidth okay
all right so let me ask you i'm just i'm
glad to to be reminded
that you can send a colony of people
right and they can get anywhere they
want
in their lifetime provided they travel
fast enough
so now let me ask you this uh let's say
they want to get
there they they're going to go someplace
even further right we're talking about
true interstellar travel right
intergalactic intergalactic yeah because
they're going to another galaxy
all right and then they're coming back
okay
and they have kids and kids
what would that do and maybe this is
outside of your purview i don't know
what would that do to us as a species
would would they be that much different
from not having any of the effects of
being on this spinning rock
going around this little teeny star that
we live in right now
that's beyond my purview no i would say
that it is possible to speciate
one of the ways you make you split a
species is you strand
a variety of yourself in a place and
then
there's no more communication that's why
every freaking animal looks so different
on
in australia okay but you still need
sufficient time
during their isolated periods and in
this case it could only be even a
handful of generations right right right
but there would be generations as you
said who would never have experienced
life on planet earth but you also need
pressure to select against some features
and promote others
so that those features then become
something else
that have are not recognizable to where
you came from okay
so so you need that and if if that ship
is exactly the environment that earth
right and it's always been and always
a1g and you do all this yeah yeah you're
not really creating a circumstance where
there's
a pressure to a pressure but if you
create a reality show where it's
survivor on the ship
right and then you have artificial
pressures yeah you could drive this
space
into some different places that's kind
of wild that yeah yeah
i think so it wouldn't be natural
selection be artificial selection yeah
that's right yeah you just inject them
from the ship if they uh
all right we're gonna space you okay all
right next question let's let's do the
next question
all right here we go uh this is cheyenne
leo
who is also from patreon uh cheyenne leo
yeah
his name is hello mr green hi
hail from canada and i love your books
i've been wondering lately what is time
made of
i might be a little out there but i was
thinking that it must be made of
something
because presumably it was created in the
big bang and it interacts with things
like light
and gravity light takes time to get
there gravity slows it down in extreme
circumstances etc etc
so if we can interact with other forces
shouldn't it be made of
something i love that question that's a
great question yeah when when is
something more than just an idea
when does it become a thing well this is
an idea that is starting to become a
thing right now
uh so it's certainly the case that the
intuition of the question is right on
target when we look at ordinary material
objects in the real world
they are made of stuff they're made of
molecules made of atoms made of
subatomic particles
could that idea be relevant for space
and time themselves
and people have thought about this for a
long time but recently there have been
developments in a variety of fields
string theory being one of them
where we're starting to catch a glimpse
of what the ingredients of space and
time
might actually be and in fact there's
work that's being done
that should talk about a time particle
not really a time particle per se
but it's easier to talk about this in
space even though space and time are
really the same thing but
we have some evidence that space itself
may be stitched by the threads of
quantum
entanglement so this idea of quantum
entanglement that
links together distant objects in a way
that makes it
appear as though they're right next to
each other in terms of their physical
properties
it may be that the threads of quantum
entanglement are
the stitches in the fabric of space-time
itself is this where you get to the idea
that in the distant future
where dark energy accelerates us
ever greater that it might accelerate us
faster than quantum
phenomenon can keep up creating a tear
in the fabric of space-time
yeah and in fact you don't even need to
know about the ingredients in the form
you didn't face in the comments
pause when i said that that means it
could really happen yes so so the idea
that the dark energy
might get stronger over time so right
now we all know that there is dark
energy pushing the distance
away we've spoken about this before
we actually have spoken about this
so but it's possible that that dark
energy gained strength over time
which means that it would not only drive
the distant galaxies away ever more
quickly
but it would start to drive even planets
away from their stars
and it would even drive electrons away
from the nucleus of atoms
which would rip matter apart and yes
you're right depending on the very
nature of space-time
it could be that this dark energy
growing over time might
sunder space itself might rip the fabric
of space apart
that's amazing we're talking about the
actual tearing of the universe itself i
don't even want to think about that
now i should point out that since you
brought up the terry the fabric of space
a paper that i wrote with a couple
colleagues years ago was the first
mathematical demonstration within string
theory that the fabric of space can rip
apart
in a manner that would not yield a
catastrophe the fabric of space would
repair itself and it would just be
a new behavior within the repertoire of
things that space can accomplish that
einstein would never have thought of but
einstein didn't think about quantum
mechanics and the general theory of
relativity and when you unite them as
string theory does
you get new things that space and time
can do and one of them may be
tearing apart and it repairs itself and
repairs it so it may not be
an appointment for that we have a save
put some ice on it it's not so much
the strings and string theory can
surround the tear and form more of a
band-aid
so it's more that the strings form a
band-aid that protects us from the rip
and the fabric of space but see
and there's math behind this it's not
like i was going to say because you look
very
skeptical i did too because that sounds
just because there's math don't
go don't hide behind this man i'm not
hiding i'm just trying to i'm just
saying
math can talk about some crazy stuff
that had nothing to do with reality
and you know it don't tell me there's
math behind it so therefore
this emerges right from the most natural
interpretation of the equations of
strength
so i'm not standing on my head to make
this happen okay okay that's an
important point
it is because there's a lot of stuff
that we think about where you have to go
out in left field to try to get the
explanation
but if this flows out of your stuff
naturally yeah it's a beautiful thing
yeah
very cool i'll tell you what else
happened black holes
shrink down to a very small size very
small mass and they transmute into
elementary particles
so black holes that you normally think
as being kind of this big thing out in
the cosmos different from the
fundamental constituents of matter
when space rips the process that repairs
it
involves black holes turning into
particles so you know he just made that
yeah
no no you had me until i was there with
the repairs itself
no no no no black holes black holes are
the doctors
and the nurses no i'm sorry
no you're foolish
[Laughter]
oh man oh no we got ready for this
segment
no no we're not this is great stuff when
we come back
oh i wish we were here every day brian
oh that was good
cosmic queries until the end of time
questions from the heart of the cosmos
when they return the great courses plus
is a subscription on-demand video
learning service with top-notch lectures
and courses from top professors from the
ivy league and other great
universities globally and experts from
places like
national geographic the smithsonian and
the culinary institute of america
through your subscription you get access
to a huge library of over 11
000 video lectures about anything that
interests you
from science math history literature
even how to cook play chess
or become a better photographer and we
know you're intellectually curious so we
know you're going to love it
speaking of better photography i've
always wanted to take better pictures
and thanks to the great courses plus
that's happening
i am taking the fundamentals of
photography with joel satori a pro
photog from national geographic
i'm learning about lighting and
composition and most of all
how to take interesting photos stream
and enjoy
for your tv your laptop your tablet your
phone
or through any web browser by using the
great courses plus
app learn at your own pace when and
where you want
now the great courses plus is giving you
a great
offer of a free trial show your support
for star talk radio
by subscribing to the great courses plus
please visit
the great courses plus star talk radio
click on the link in the description
below to start
your free trial today
we're back star talk
cosmic queries we've got brian greene
here the one the only longtime friend
colleague love this man to death he's
been a friend of star talk from the
beginning
from the beginning this is not his first
rodeo no with us here
uh so brian uh congratulations on your
fourth book thank you
and got a great write-up in the new york
times very enthusiastic
write-up and even when he was
criticizing it he was praising it
yeah right it's like oh it got
complicated but it needed that and i
kind of liked it
and it got me into it you know it was
like one of those kind of things so who
actually reviews
your books i'm serious like you two guys
you
write these books who is it that sits
down
and says okay let me go through here
this is mom
brian's mother intimate employee for the
new york times yes
son i have to tell you i don't know
about this whole thing about black holes
and particles
[Laughter]
so no really who who who is it i mean
there's a scientist
a lot of people that can do that they're
science editors that's their job
they can't handle it then they don't
review it
the plenty of newspapers don't review
science books oh actually the number of
reviews of science books is going down
because uh newspapers are really winning
together
yeah
they're cutting their staff so they
can't afford it wow
wow so this just to give him credit
because he's he's he's in the club
um dennis overby long time science
writer and editor
one of the best really for the new york
times and he leans
cosmological although when we demoted
pluto here
he wanted to dip into that when i said
there's not you're a beat
you know this is too nearby for you but
i think he wanted some pluto street cred
right so he did a little pluto article
on on our demotion and was he
was he for or against your postulate
he he was antagonistic oh okay yeah
yeah all right but anyhow he's a long
time editor and he has a book of his own
oh yeah so the real the real question is
who would actually review his book
i think he wrote a book the lonely
hearts of the cosmos which was about
um two astronomers trying to find the
scale of the universe was that the book
i'm remembering i i don't remember the
details
okay but it was biographical okay uh
astronomers who had access to big
telescopes all right and you're
there at night looking up at the night
sky with the telescope
and nobody else lonely hearts of the
cosmos okay that sounds about right
okay no no i'm joking here we go let's
let's get back to our questions uh this
is um
uh cs hold on lower so people can see
your beautiful face
all right here we go see us till one i
forgot we're on camera too um
hey do you think the laws of physics are
finite and
knowable can we ever fully understand
the universe in its entirety
if so what forces might we be able to
manipulate
uh that are beyond us now
that's a very very cool question no it's
a deep question
because look you look around the world
and there are intelligent beings walking
around
dogs right and they don't we think
understand the general theory of
relativity or quantum mechanics so these
are intelligence brains
although when i say that i always think
the dogs are about their barking and
saying oh he thinks you don't understand
general relativity
you know but but seeing if that's really
the case then why do we think that the
human brain
would be able to understand it all we
may have limitations on the deep truths
that we're able to grasp
now having said that there's no evidence
that there's any limit to what we can
figure out we haven't hit the wall
right we did develop quantum mechanics
we did develop relativity
you know wait you and your compatriots
have been at this string theory thing
for 30 years yeah here we go maybe here
we go
maybe that's the wall it could be maybe
you guys aren't smart enough you found
the wall but but here's what i would say
to that let me hold the mirror to you
here okay
who's the one who can't find who's at
the edge of the wall see but that would
only be the case
if we were sitting here saying we can't
make any progress in understanding the
mathematics
theory and we're making incredible
progress but the thing is and the part
that you're responding to which is
completely justified
we haven't been able to make contact
with observation or experiment
but that's not all that surprising when
you're dealing with a theory
whose energy scale is like 10 to the 15
10 to the 16 times greater than that of
the large hadron collider or most
powerful machine in geneva switzerland
so i agree that we have hit roadblocks
but it's not us
theorists it's the experimenter
and if i might chime in here if i might
chime in here let me just add
that's the dog saying we have the
solution but you just
there's your answer guys you're
neutering us and you're taking us to
and you're feeding me alpo i don't know
okay cool man oh that's a great answer
so it's a great answer wait wait so let
me
let me let me give a nuance to that
question and hand it back to him all
right okay
um are there mit do you believe
there may be missing laws of physics
that'll help us get
further or that kind of all the laws of
physics are there
we just need to be more creative with
what we've got hmm yeah i think it would
be hubris
that's a little bit of that yes it is it
is different yeah to think that we
really
have it right now would be sort of the
classic act of hubris right
i mean every time we thought we figured
it all out there was a new law there was
a new particle there was something else
to find so i would imagine
at sufficiently high energy scales we're
going to find new stuff
new parts entry scales would be beyond
where anyone has gone before right
to boldly go yeah so let's say we've
basically gone on the order of uh
10 000 times the mass of a proton
roughly speaking energy
energy energy scale and we haven't found
anything new
yet but i would imagine that between
that scale and the so-called planck
scale which is where
the fundamental laws of quantum
mechanics and gravity come together
that's 10 to the 19 times the mass of a
proton
so that's 19 orders of magnitude bigger
than a proton
and we've only gone up to sort of four
orders of magnitude
bigger than a proton so in that range
i suspect there's going to be something
new to be found okay interesting because
they
because just in all fairness to those
who've come before us they would be on
working in a tabletop right and there'd
be some phenomenon they don't understand
and then they'd experiment with it and
then they isolate it and name it and
and characterize it and mathematize it
yes and so
our basic known four forces of nature
come out of that kind of experiment
exactly kind of tabletop plus
simple particle accelerators right and
astronomical observations
yeah and observations so what you're
saying is that's a regime
that manifested some aspects of nature
that we have
figured out in in a tidy way yeah but
there could be bigger questions we don't
even
get to yet because we haven't tested the
regime
and that regime is not on our table too
exactly okay yeah that means the future
of physics is big
big money big accelerators uh that
but i also like to think that if we're
sufficiently clever
we might find indirect ways of probing
realms that you think would require that
big machine but maybe we can be smarter
about it okay on star trek it's just all
computer simulations so by the way just
uh
as a signal to my people being clever
it was how are you going to put a big
telescope in orbit well
you can't put a make a rocket that wide
no so you
build it yeah well you can build it in
space or
you can get a mirror that unfurls right
all of a sudden the engineers say hey i
got this
right let me be clever and figure it out
so we've actually
overcome many challenges that previously
were considered intractable just by
clever people yeah exactly i'm echoing
your point yeah cool exactly right
that is super cool super cool super cool
all right here we go
this is jane 9117
says finding slash creating your own
meaning is fine
but objectively what do you think brian
is the actual meaning of this creation
yeah yeah because meaning is that's a
big part of where you try to go in this
book yeah
and and the answer that i give to that
question to develop
completely and more you know more fully
i should say not completely in the book
is that there is no ultimate meaning
floating out there in the void
right throughout these i gotta go
through all these pages and to find out
that there's
i'm gonna give you these i gotta read
this for you to tell me there's no
meaning cliff notes
cliff notes right here so the cliff
notes are that we are the product of the
mindless purposeless laws of physics
we are all just bags of particles
governed by those iron clad
that's it and what we have the capacity
to do which is remarkable
is impose order impose coherence impose
purpose and meaning on the external
world and the internal conscious
experience
and so it's not as though there are two
things the real answer that's floating
out there in the void awaiting our
discovery
and sort of the internal one that we
manufacture it is
only the internal one that we
manufacture because there is
nothing else how do you know this i
don't know this beyond
my experience in a lifetime of working
with the laws of nature the particles of
nature and trying to give explanations
for the things that we observe in the
external world
so the particles are your gods well uh
you know
there is a place for religion you need
to answer that if you're really way
faster
let me think about it walter has some
neutrinos on it but
yeah no no but but honestly seriously i
do think there's a
role for religion that some of our
colleagues step on and
dismiss out of hand entirely and what
would that be well it's not
to understand the external world no one
can use any religious doctrine to
calculate the electrons magnetic moment
to nine decimal places which is what we
can do
routinely with quantum field theory but
if you think about religion and the
spiritual
journey is something that doesn't
illuminate the external world but rather
the internal world of any conscious
experience
for meaning in life yes exactly then
there is a role for it and
and you don't judge it by whether it can
explain the external world
that's not what it's meant to do you
judge it by whether
it is a satisfying way of trying to
understand your place in the universe
ninety percent of religious people would
say that the other ten percent were
fundamentalists yeah of course go down
get their science out of the out of the
bible i agree right now that's
problematic it enlightened religious
people
or where you're where you're coming from
i agree that's very good that was an uh
that was that was a little journey i
liked it i still think he's got an altar
in his in his home
he sacrifices to the particle gods
i'm pretty sure i'm pretty sure about
that all right
okay let's move on to uh
lee bird okay um
so lee bird from facebook says hello dr
tyson
and dr greene my wife has asked
where where
does our universe end not how
but where does our universe end and i
would like to say
are there more than one ending is there
an ending and then more endings are
there levels of
that's a time ending rather than a
placement well that's what i'm saying
all right but is this a place ending
that's what i'm hearing
that's the point no you think it's a
total where where
and look the quick answer is we don't
know okay but the possibilities are
space could go on
infinitely far in which case there never
would be an end that's a strange idea to
us beings that live
in a finite environment but nevertheless
the math allows that as a real
possibility
or space could be curved which means you
could go out in that direction
and ultimately circle back and return to
your starting point
so there again wouldn't be an end but
nevertheless
the space would be finite in its extent
right so these are sort of two big parts
so you can travel with things
infinitely finite space yeah infinite
yeah you could go infinitely far but it
would be a finite place
like the surface of the earth like the
surface of the earth exactly
i can tell you this yes it offers some
insight we look out to the edge of the
observable universe okay
and we see light that has been traveling
for 13.8 billion years okay
that gives us evidence
of the big bang for that part of the
universe experiencing it
at the time it emitted that light that
horizon continues to push out
right as long as we keep seeing evidence
of the big bang
we are still moving into a universe
that's our whole
right imagine the day where that
horizon washes over the last bit of
matter
that experienced the big bang then the
information coming to us
about the big bang ceases and all of
what we know of cosmology would have no
data set at that point
and at that point you're basically the
moving horizon which gets one light year
away from us per year right at that
speed
would have overtaken the last matter of
the universe and that would be the edge
of the universe
do you agree with that well there's a
there's a version of that that i think i
can
agree with more precisely which is i
meant no but
that wasn't very very difficult he's a
guest he's gotta be polite hey by the
way
i am taking notes i gotta learn to talk
to my wife
i have got to learn how to talk to her
like this just like would you agree
well there's a version that i would
agree with more precisely
with the deer exactly he didn't say dear
but i get a deer
at least a deer at least
so so even right now with the
accelerated expansion of space
we can do calculations that show us
quite clearly that the distant galaxies
that we have used to figure out the
space is expanding
they are going to disappear over the
cosmological horizon we will not be able
to see them in roughly 100 billion or a
trillion years
okay so the evidence that we've used to
even figure out that space is expanding
it's going away it's going away right
okay which is a strange thing because
the expansion will overtake yeah the the
the matter that is giving us this
information
will overtake the the moving horizon
yes and then then it's a moot point yeah
yeah it'll basically drop
over a cliff at the edge of space which
is the horizon because it's moving away
so quickly yeah
running your headlights that's what
you're doing yeah yeah
that's cool man all right we gotta take
a break oh really i know this is so good
i know
i forgot we were doing a show i know
right
of course i didn't get my deer out of
that
deer that's a different
all right star talk cosmic queries brian
green chuck knight we'll be right back
start talk we're back cosmic queries
until the end of time
search for meaning in the universe
and ryan green goes there
he does and how many pages brian oh it's
only 300. a lot of endnotes
that's why i look so thick oh oh there
you go there you go that's a nice
picture of you oh thank you yeah
nice picture in the end wow and it's
recently yeah yeah yeah and handsome
yeah it was five minutes
five minutes ago not like a tinder
picture like wait a minute this dude is
23.
so chuck give us the question all right
that's our last thing let's see how many
we can squeeze in real quick we'll get
on
quick let me just ask a quick question
for myself all right we're able
this is hypothetical because we're not
able to but we're able to get beyond
this
horizon that you were talked about we're
able to observe that
they're whatever right but now we are
outside
of the universe that was created at the
big bang what is time
in that place well it could be the same
as time here
so so that that cosmological horizon is
as as neil is pointing out
just the distance that we can possibly
see because light has had the time
to travel from it to us since the big
bang but it could be that
time applies throughout this realm of
space and it could be that it looks out
there much like it looks in here
it's not as how you pass through it and
you've been in some entirely new domain
however it's possible that it could be
different since we've never been there
the math suggests that it will be the
same but we're at different that would
be
shocking and wonderful wait wait but
brian let me take issue with that yeah
please
the horizon is not a real place yeah
it's just the
property of where we are because i speed
of light yes
so that's what i meant well when i'm a
ship at sea yeah
and i go to my horizon right whatever 10
miles away
now i have a new horizon and i'm still
it's still safe exactly so why are you
telling me something different
that's my point i believe that that will
be the case in the universe
but it's also conceivable that is not
what he said no no but it's conceivable
you would agree
that when you take your ship it's
possible that when you reach your
current horizon
it could be that things are completely
different it could be the dragons or
there
it could it could be the gates of hell
dragon never or you'd have to presume
that at exactly that distance and you
were in the middle of where all those
dragons were and that's kind of special
space that's a very good thing it's very
supposed to be
that that's the point so i can't go
wrong with that yeah so if i didn't say
it clearly right i suspect if you said
it
correctly argues that it will be the
same right out there
but it's conceivable it's conceivable
that it would be difficult yeah but i
get
what i really get out of that and maybe
it just helped me out here
what you're saying then is what we are
seeing
is a reference that's what we're seeing
yeah we're not really seeing
edge we're not seeing we're seeing a
reference is what we're saying any more
than a ship at sea
that's not the edge of the earth you can
think it's the edge of the earth and it
might be the edge of the earth
it probably isn't however
oh getting too much time to think yeah
my brain is going
i should point out i should point out
that in a universe
where the spatial expansion is
accelerating
that cosmological horizon would actually
have a temperature you're right
it's not a real location in space but
from that spot we would have
heat emerging that would give a
background temperature that at the
moment would be about 10 to the minus
30 kelvin so it actually has a physical
presence even though it is in some sense
just a reference it's a thing to measure
i love that i think to measure yeah that
is i love things to measure moreover can
i point out
just since we're going on this tangent
that temperature that comes from that
distant cosmological horizon
may imperil the future of thought itself
uh-oh so one of the things i describe in
the book is that in the far future and
that's where the book ends the thought
is
so any cogitating being through the act
of thought has to release heat right
second law thermodynamic yes
yeah and if it's the case that that
cogitating being can't release its heat
it will burn up
and because of the heat emitted by the
distant cosmological horizon
in the far future a cogitating being
will not be able to release that heat
and if it but that's not very much heat
i know
but in the far future that's all you got
that's all you got oh that's all you got
yeah so you're saying oh yeah
this is scary don't tell me this yeah oh
now i'm sad
yeah let me know now you're gonna read
the book no no okay no now let me
let me repeat what i think you said yeah
that every act of thinking
is a thermodynamic um electrochemical
process as far as we know yeah okay so
that creates heat that
needs to dissipate so that you can have
your next thought yeah
if the bath the thermal bath in which
you were immersed
has a greater temperature than the
temperature of your
thoughts then your thoughts
will back up and overheat
and you can't sustain that yeah that's
the basically like an overloading
phaser yeah yeah yes yeah yeah very now
now it's the brain of the thinking
that's being actually doing it so it
tries to think about all about the
overlapping and it self-destructs
sucks wow all right let's get back to
this
uh okay all right we're short on time
okay all right all right what do you got
uh
here we go um this is juan 911
on instagram nine one he says hi neil
and brian it's not 9-1-1
it's just it is 9-1-1 it is it is okay
all right you are absolutely right it's
9-1-1 uh and he goes uh hi neil and
brian and maybe chuck
uh my question is the following
hypothetically if we were
living in a universe where we can
increase or lower the entropy
would it be possible to travel in time
greetings from montreal i really love
the podcast and it makes my community
awesome so let me reshape that so more
people can be part of that
so as you know and as you've written um
the increase of entropy is one of the
arrows of time so if we somehow had
control over entropy
in the universe to reverse it will that
imbue us with powers over the hour of
time i don't think so
so you're right we often do think about
entropy and it's relentless increase as
an arrow of time
but if it were to reverse itself time
would still
carry on in the direction that it was
always traveling we would just see some
weird things
happening in the environment around us
we might see for instance
eggs on break or candles unburned but it
wouldn't be time going backward it'd be
those physical
processes going backwards okay so now if
everything
went backwards that would be something
else but that's not what the question is
it's just right
we're able to reduce entropy in summary
okay so if if we're
we're able to reduce entropy of the
universe because we know we can do it
locally that's what life is yeah life is
a
is a increase is
um life is organized matter
so it has lower entropy than it would
otherwise have if life did not form are
you getting using energy from the sun
basically to do this so uh if you
we somehow did have power over entropy
of the entire universe do you think that
would have any consequences at all well
yeah i mean it would
radically change our predictions for
what will happen in the far future
you know okay yeah yeah yeah things that
our understanding of nature
is so intermixed intertwined with
an increase in entropy that if entropy
systemically decreased we'd have to
rethink what what what's cause and what
was effect
that's right and we'd have to rethink
where we are headed in the far future
yeah yeah okay
dude that's really cool okay all right
let's do this one and i have to rewrite
one of the chapters in my book
team fourth scythe uh team forsyth
observatory
um on instagram would like to know hello
neil brian and chuck
what do you all believe would be the
world's religions
response when we are contacted
from another civilization
outside of our own existence give it to
me
yeah i don't think it will make all that
much of a difference
i think the the nature of uh reality for
us scientists would
change completely because now we'd have
a second instantiation of life out there
in the universe which would be
a radical moment but i think for the
world intelligent life
because they're here even better you
know but for the world religions i don't
think that there'd be
much of a difference because they have a
certain perspective
on where we've come from and why we're
here and what we're doing and i don't
think that the existence of
additional intelligent life would really
change things in any substantial way oh
okay let me
let me just put let me do this for both
of you here's the deal that same
thing yeah but now here's the deal those
beings tell us
we put you here now what do the
religions do
well so there's already religion about
that what they call the ray aliens
what what i'm just saying i'm just
saying it's true
yes it's just really the ray aliens so
so this religion is a religion
where god is not god as imagined in the
in the hebrew bible but god is
an intelligent race of aliens that
created us
really and so there's strong overlap
with a god because if a god created us
and they're the external thing there's a
creator a creator right so that you've
got
the alien so there's a whole religion
that's already there is my point
so they would just be like told you
exactly
but to your point there are some
religions where or some
branches of religions where it is very
important to them
that the universe was created for us and
for no other life
they would have an issue with this but
most religions have gotten past that
and religions are more than just belief
systems they're also institutions
and institutions generally have their
own survival as a fundamental part of
what they do and why they do it
and moreover there are so many religions
already practiced on planet earth and
each one needs to deal with the
existence of the
others and they're able to do that by
virtue of saying ours is a real one and
theirs is not so i think we'd have that
same kind of response
if aliens came down but to your point
about ray aliens if that's the name of
it
there's also the simulation hypothesis
right if we are
all just a simulation of future
supercomputer then again there's a
god-like being
the kid in the garage who's fired up the
supercomputer and again you don't have
anything supernatural
and yet we would be the outcome of a
creator's
desires wishes whims because that kid
fired up that simulation hmm okay
so he has another alter and there's a
kid
the kid god as well as the party altar
right
god said all right let's uh let's see if
we can get another one in this is i
think we can
oscott um he says
on from twitter since the beginning of
our civilization the human
mind and consciousness have evolved
so much can the human brain figure out
the human consciousness in what ways
uh can we confidently predict that we
will acquire the ability to comprehend
the majesty of the cosmos
so do you get into consciousness i do
yeah there's a whole uh yeah yeah so
so we gotta go quick what what's your
take on it my take is that consciousness
is
an exquisite physical process but
nothing more than a physical process it
is simply
particles coursing through a gloppy gray
structure inside our heads again
fully determined by physical law do you
think it was emergent and is the
organism yes
it certainly emerged by virtue of the
organization
of this structure inside of our heads i
don't think there's anything else beyond
the particles and the laws of physics
required for consciousness to exist
i mean do you no no i i'm not convinced
by
so much of what's written about
consciousness i mean the fact that
there's so many books on consciousness
and everyone's over it means no one
knows anything about it
the evidence you don't know anything is
people keep writing about it right how
many people are still writing about
einstein general relativity
it's on the show of course yeah yeah
right yeah so it is but i agree
i think everyone agreed is the grand
mystery you know where does
consciousness come from
and many take the approach that we uh
know historically
people use with life people thought
vitalism it couldn't just be particles
in the laws of physics you got to inject
something else a life force
right nobody talks that way any longer
right and now some christians will talk
about a soul
right but few scientists think that way
any longer similarly there are some
scientists who think you have to inject
something
into the particles and the forces to get
conscious self-awareness
i think a hundred or a thousand or
whatever number of years from now people
will look back and smile at how quaint
that idea was but there's nothing more
than particles
and physical laws what did what was the
question about consciousness though
did we ever be able to con will we be
able to understand
consciousness and then imagine that
being able to understand or comprehend
the majesty of the
cosmos so let me reshape that so is
there a level of consciousness that
awaits us
that will enable us to appreciate the
cosmos even deeper than we already yeah
i
certainly hope so you know what a level
of awareness you know i think as
we learn more about reality we reshape
our sense of who we are and what the
grand mysteries of existence are and i
think that's a beautiful
journey that we've been on for thousands
of years and it will carry onward
cool those are some final thoughts those
are very good final thoughts yeah brian
you don't come by often enough invite me
i'll be here
dear we have to ride him we have to
invite him
more often than the rate at which he
writes books that's the problem
okay all right brian always good to have
you thank you
chuck that's my boy my man all right
this has been cosmic queries
i'll just have to say it the brian green
edition
all right neil degrasse tyson here your
personal astrophysicist as always
beating you
[Applause]
[Music]